vielen Dank für die Auswahl, also baut
mein Vortrag auf dem vorherigen Vortrag auf. Meine
Leistung. Es ist ein ziemlich ähnlicher Vortrag, aber
ich denke, ich versuche, einige neue Antworten
auf diese Fragen zu geben. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
[Musik]
also jeder eine gute Hand hat
Also fange ich mit der konzeptionellen Person an
und ich denke, wenn wir über
Personen sprechen, meinen wir zweierlei,
also sagen wir einerseits, dass Personen
ontologisch identische Einheiten
sind, was mit transtemporaler
Persistenz und so weiter und so weiter zu tun hat
wenn wir auch von engeln und würdeträgern sprechen
ich denke diese
beiden bedeutungen sitzen tief in tirol ich würde
sagen man kann sie nicht wirklich
unabhängig voneinander trennen sie sind
tief verwoben und das ist die
frage die mich beschäftigt  In meinem Vortrag
, wie sind sie Intervall in metaphysischen
Begriffen, und ich möchte eine Antwort auf
diese Frage geben, so sagt Erik Olson, sagte er, ich
meine, wir haben diese Beziehung
mehrmals gehört, er kodiert sie erneut, ohne Angabe
unseres Es  Entität hat
und garantiert die Übereinstimmung dessen, was
ich unsere Identität mit den tatsächlichen
Bedingungen unserer Identität unterstützte. Eine Darstellung
unserer Identität muss eine logisch
kohärente sowie andere Personen möglich machen,
daher nehme ich dies als zwei Bedeutungen des
Konsums des Konzepts von  Eine
Person nämlich ontologische logische
Fragen und normative ethische
Fragen Ich denke, dass sie wirklich
tief gehen, aber nicht alle wurden
zuerst so argumentiert. Ich meine, viele
Philosophen haben argumentiert, dass diese beiden
Bedeutungen
unterschieden oder
getrennt werden müssen, und es gibt diese stark
Unabhängigkeitsmodell Ich denke, dass Mario
diesen Begriff hier geprägt hat, Damenbuch,
am Leben bleiben, und ein Befürworter dieser Theorie
wäre sozusagen der christliche
Kursgott, weil sie sagt, ich zitiere es für sie,
diese Gründe für die persönliche Identität sind
nicht metaphysisch, sondern praktisch, ein weiteres
Zitat Ihrer Vorstellung  von sich selbst
als einheitlicher Agent nicht auf der
physikalischen Theorie basiert, seine Gründe sind
praktisch, so sie  Ich unterstreiche nur den
zweiten Begriff, der bedeutet, dass Mamie
sich der Würde oder eines Agenten oder eines moralischen
Agenten bewusst ist, und auch Eric hat sein Buch
von 1997 geschrieben und sagt ganz am
Anfang, dass es mein Ziel ist, direkt auf
die Metaphysik der persönlichen Identität
einzugehen  Überlassen Sie die ethischen Fragen
denen, die kompetenter sind, also würde ich
sagen, dass dies auch ein starkes
Unabhängigkeitsmodell ist, und es gibt, dass
ich das Zufallsmodell nennen werde, und ich
denke, dass dieser Dummy diese
Befürworter identifiziert, weil er sagt, dass er mehr darüber zitiert
Ozean einer Person mit einer
physischen Illusion einer Person sind keine
getrennten und unterschiedlichen Konzepte, sondern
nur unterschiedliche und instabile Ruhepunkte
auf demselben Kontinuum. Ich würde sagen, dass
dies sozusagen das ist, was besagt, dass
es eine Einheit dieser beiden gibt  Bedeutungen des
Konzepts einer Person Lassen Sie mich nun
einige Theorien von Lynn Baker vorstellen, die Sie alle kennen,
und sehen Sie, was sie
über diese Einheit sagt, die ihre
Verfassung ist  Sichtweise und sie argumentiert,
dass Leben und Persönlichkeit oder persönliche
Identität verschiedene Varianten von Theorien betrafen,
sagt sie, ich werde eine biologische
Theorie menschlicher Organismen verwenden, um auf
ontologischen Theorien menschlicher Personen aufzubauen, ein
weiteres Zitat betrifft die
Frage nach Personen und Leben und  Sie
sagt, dass dies unterschiedliche Arten sind,
sie sind wirklich getrennt und
erregt viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit. Sie sagt, dass es heute
drei ontologische Hauptansätze für menschliche
Personen gibt, Animalismus,
Substanzdualismus und meine eigene Verfassungsansicht.
Gemäß der Verfassungsansicht bestehen menschliche
Personen nur aus menschlichen
Körpern  Das sind menschliche Tiere, genauso wie
Marmorstatuen vollständig
aus Marmorstücken bestehen, jede konkrete Energie
ist im Wesentlichen von irgendeiner primären Art oder
anderem, nichts kann mehr als
eine primäre Art sein
primäre Arten
wie Standard und Stück Marmor sind
letztendlich  menschliche Prozessarchonen
durch Aggregate von Partikeln, so wie
letztendlich Marmorkanten
aus Aggregaten von Partikeln bestehen, menschliche Personen
sind genauso materiell wie Marmorstatuten,
also möchte ich
diese Aggregationstheorie sozusagen herausfordern
und durch eine andere
Theorie ersetzen  nämlich durch eine Theorie des Lebens von
Lebensformen, also richtet sich mein Einwand gegen
Bakers Verfassung, dass menschliche Personen
keine Ansammlung von Partikeln sind, sondern ein Paragon
von Partikeln, die speziell
durch die Lebensform organisiert und zusammengesetzt sind
, ist mein Einwand, und sie hat eine
andere interessante Theorie, die ich habe  finde sie
auf den ersten blick sehr plausibel sie sagt im
grunde, dass das menschensein
in gewisser weise von äußeren umständen abhängt und sie
stellt sozusagen einen person raum vor den
sie könnte sie beschreibt das in anlehnung an
eine kunstwelt ich zitiere eine passage sie
sagt g günstig  Umstände sind das
Milieu, in dem etwas sein kann G das
G günstige Umstände das
sind die notwendigen aber n  Es reicht nicht
aus, dass etwas ein G ist, wenn dann, wenn ein
passendes F in G günstigen
Umständen ist, es zu einem
GV kommt, wenn ein Stück Marmor nicht so
günstig ist, dann
kommt es dazu, dass seine Daten den
Zustand günstiger Umstände darstellen  es
hängt von der richtigen theorie ab
deine günstigen umstände können
die existenz existenz eines
kunstwerks die absichten bildhauer das
aussehen des stücks modell
was auch immer es braucht, damit etwas eine
statue ist
ich fand diesen begriff
kunstwelt in diesem zitat sehr interessant weil  Ich
meine, wie Sie alle wissen, ist es ein Begriff
, der 64 von Dan Toe geprägt wurde.
Er sagt, dass etwas als etwas zu sehen, was
wir brauchen, etwas erfordert, das ich nicht
beschreiben kann, eine Atmosphäre
der Kunsttheorie, des Wissens über die Geschichte der Kunst und der
Kunstwelt, also wenn es eine gibt  Diese Analogie
zur Kunstwelt kann nicht sagen, dass Baker
so etwas wie eine
Personenwelt in Bezug auf günstige
Umstände für eine Person denkt  g gut
konstituiert, also ist meine Frage,
was ist der ontologische Status wie eine
Kunstwelt und ob es
sich um eine persönliche Welt handelt
, die von Medizinern konstituiert wird,
gibt es eine weitere interessante Passage in
ihrer Theorie, dass Künstler nicht alle
Menschen sind  Menschen, sagt sie, seien vielleicht
schwer autistische Personen oder
schwer behinderte Personen, die nur
rudimentäre Ich-
Perspektiven haben, in diesem Fall sind
sie alle noch sehr beeinträchtigt,
weil sie
Ich-Perspektiven empfohlen haben und eine
Art menschliches Tier sind  entwickelt die
robuste Ich-Perspektive gibt es ein
weiteres Zitat und sie sagt, dass die
Entstehung eines menschlichen
Organismus nicht hip ist, also berücksichtige die
Entstehung einer menschlichen Person. Ich möchte
dieses Argument in Frage stellen. Ich denke, dass
es bedeutet, ein menschlicher Organismus zu sein  Eine
Person Ich versuche, einige Argumente
für diese Theorie zu liefern, also ist eine andere wichtige
Theorie das Leben einer Person, das Sie, ich meine, wir
haben  Ich habe davon kurz zuvor von Maria
Shipman gehört und sie sagt, dass Personen
Lebewesen sind. Eine Person zu sein bedeutet, eine Person zu leben.
Lebensschutz
Meine Frage ist also, was für ein
Leben das Leben einer Person ist.
Ist es etwas, das sozial konstruiert ist wie eine
zweite Natur, also war ich mir nicht ganz sicher
über die Konzeption von Leben mit
ontologischem Status. Ich meine, Sie
haben in der Diskussion etwas darüber gesagt
und so  Wenn ja, wenn es eine Art zweite Natur ist, eine
sozial konstruierte Einheit, wie
unsere erste Natur, also unsere Biologie und unsere
zweite Natur, zusammenhängt, ohne
eine Art Dualismus, Substanzdualismus oder
was auch immer zu billigen, also ist dies hier eine Frage,
ein weiterer wichtiger Aspekt von Euer
Ehren
Mario  Die Theorie ist, dass Personen
notwendigerweise in einem persönlichen Raum existieren
, wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe,
weil wir
die besondere Praxis aus dem neuesten Buch der Braut zitieren  es und
Institutionen werden natürlich von
Ort zu Ort variieren und von Zeit zu Zeit
wird nur behauptet, dass es
solche Praktiken und Institutionen geben wird, und
dann ist es notwendig, dass es
einige gibt, wenn
diese Infrastruktur überhaupt leben soll
einen Personenraum zu definieren, indem die
breiten Parameter festgelegt werden, innerhalb derer
zwischenmenschliche Interaktionen stattfinden
, in die Lebensform der Person gebracht zu werden,
kann so beschrieben werden, dass
ihnen ein Platz in den Teilnehmern eingeräumt wird. Was
ich an dieser Rotation interessant fand,
ist die Konzeption von a  Form der Verweigerung der
Person Es ist ein formaler Aspekt. Ich möchte
diesen Formaspekt zeichnen. Ich sage, wir tun
es, aber ich werde ein weiteres
entscheidendes Zitat
entwickeln  ist nicht willkürlich, also habe ich eine
andere Frage, also auf welche Weise ist
dies nicht willkürlich, über die
ich ein bisschen mehr nachdenken möchte, sie
alle  so heißt es, dass Personen mehr als
nur Tiere sind, sind unsere tierischen Funktionen und
Interaktionen niemals rein tierisch,
sondern immer von forensischer
Bedeutung und Struktur
durchdrungen, also lautet hier meine Frage, inwiefern Personen mehr
als nur Tiere sind, wie man sich diesen Überschuss vorstellen kann,
was sein muss  einem Tier hinzugefügt wird,
um zuerst zu werden, was
im Leben eines fast natürlichen
Wesens geändert werden muss, um eine Person zu werden, also
werde ich jetzt für einen Mittelweg argumentieren,
einen Mittelweg zwischen
Lockean ISM und einer Art Animalismus  der
hybriden Sichtweise, wie Harold sie vor zwei
Tagen entwickelt hatte, aber ich versuche es auf eine
andere Weise, aber ich würde es auch gerne
einen Mittelweg nennen, einen Mittelweg
zwischen Larcenist und der psychologischen
Sichtweise und dem Animalismus,
also was ich vorhabe  Sie müssen sich an
Lockes Theorie halten, um für einen solchen Mittelweg zu argumentieren
, denn in der Protokollidentitätstheorie
sagt er, wie Sie alle wissen, dass
Person ein forensischer Begriff ist, der sich
Handlungen aneignet, und sie sind verheiratet und gehören daher
nur zu int  Intelligente Agenten
, die zu einem Gesetz und Glück und Elend fähig sind
Ich denke, dass in Lockes
Theorie diese
Einheitsfragen auch eine moralisch-ethische Frage sind,
also würde ich sagen, dass sogar in Lockes
Theorie eine Art
Zufallsmodell über die eigene persönliche Existenz vorhanden ist, also
hier ist Yardas drei  Arten von Identitäten
, die er unterscheidet, sagt er, dass
es eine Sache ist, dieselbe Substanz zu sein, ein
anderer derselbe Mann und eine dritte dieselbe
persönliche Person. Hauptsubstanz sind drei
Namen, die für drei verschiedene Ideen
stehen  Wichtig dabei
ist die Identität desselben Menschen,
die uns nichts anderes als eine
Teilhabe desselben fortgesetzten Lebens
durch ständig flüchtige
Spiegelpartikel nacheinander vital vereint
zu demselben organisierten Körper ist. Ich möchte
diese vitale Einheit betonen, die Sie daran erinnert, dass
es sich um ein Drachengedicht handelt  vorher so ist es
auf eine besondere weise aufgebaut das ist ein
organismus das ist sozusagen die ebene
des tiers ist die zweite art des menschen a  Und
da unterscheidet er eine dritte Art
von Identität, sie treffen auf die Identität der
Person, und er sagt, dass verschiedene Substanzen
durch dasselbe Bewusstsein, wo
sie aufgenommen wurden,
ebenfalls vereint sind, aber jetzt in einer
Person, sowie verschiedene Körper
durch dasselbe Leben in einem vereint sind  Tier,
dessen Identität in der
Veränderung von Stoffen durch die Einheit von einem erhalten
bleibt. Sie möchten dies ebenso betonen,
wie auch das auf eine Art
Analogie hinweist, die ich in Worten zeichne,
die folgen werden. Ich fand dies sehr wichtig,
weil es das gibt  die wichtige analogie
zwischen der identität des lebens und der
identität einer person besteht hier in dieser
speziellen einheit, denn so gibt es die
analogie identität von personen mit der identität
von organismen, sie wissen gewisses
wissen
um die identität von organismen und es ist
nicht ganz dasselbe, aber  Es ist die Form
, die diese Einheit ergibt, die diese Einheit ausmacht.
Also, was für eine Analogie ist das, und ich
würde sagen, es ist eine Analogie der Form
, und ich möchte das zeichnen  Analogie Sie
alle kennen dieses hier dieses Zitat, das er
sagt, sollte die Seele eines Prinzen
das Bewusstsein des vergangenen Lebens des Prinzen mit sich
tragen und den Körper eines Gemeinen informieren,
sobald er von seinem eigenen verlassen wird, damit
jeder sieht, dass er dieselbe
Person wäre  wobei der Prinz nur
für die Handlungen des Prinzen verantwortlich ist, so wie ich
dies zuvor betont habe, gibt es eine Formel
, um einen Teil zu finden, also ist meine Idee, dass die
folgenden Personen und Leben keine
unterschiedlichen Kategorien sind, sondern die Komplexität
formaler Personen besondere Formen des Lebens
und des persönlichen Lebens unseres Lebens sind  von
Form zweiter Ordnung, was auch immer Form zweiter Ordnung ist,
ich versuche, ein bisschen mehr
davon freizusetzen, damit diese Form zweiter Ordnung
in Bezug auf Selbstbewusstsein
und Freiheit des Willens verwirklicht wird
Nehmen Sie einen ähnlichen Weg, also
lassen Sie uns vor kurzem
einige transformative
Konzepte der Persönlichkeit vorgeschlagen haben, die ich
sehr hilfreich finde, da ist das Beste,
argumentiert Boyle die letzten  Die Veröffentlichung
unserer Fähigkeit zur Rationalität ergänzt nicht
nur die tierischen Fähigkeiten
zur Wahrnehmung des Begehrens, sondern transformiert sie
auf eine Weise, die diese
Fähigkeiten wesentlich von der
entsprechenden Fähigkeit eines
irrationalen Feindes unterscheidet  er ist der vater
ohne vater
jede transformative theorie sagt, dass die
gesamte organisation aller menschlichen kräfte
die gesamte häusliche ökonomie des wesentlichen
als kompromittierende und
willentliche natur erkannt wird oder vielmehr eine einzelne
positive gedankenkraft,
die eine suchorganisation des
körpers hervorbringt  beim Menschen Vernunft heißt
, so wie es
bei unseren Tieren zum Gebäude wird, das
beim Menschen Freiheit heißt und
beim Tier wiederum zum Instinkt wird, das
Anderssein liegt nicht in den Ebenen oder eine
zusätzliche Kraft im Ausland in einem ganz
anderen  Orientierung und Entfaltung
aller Kraft, so ist dies die eigentliche Idee  A der
Transformation Hier habe ich eine andere Frage,
denn was genau bedeutet Transformation
, wie ist der Übergang von einem,
das der tierische Körperorganismus ist
, zu zwei, nämlich Menschen oder
zu zeugenden Personen?
Ich meine, Transformation ist nur eine Bezeichnung
für diesen sehr dunklen Prozess  ein
bisschen ähnlich wie Emergenz, also ist meine Frage,
was das tierische Leben in ein
menschliches Leben umwandelt, ist es eine einzige Fähigkeit wie
Griechenland
und Selbstbewusstsein, weil der Junge, den meine
Mutter geerntet hat, das
Selbstbewusstsein ist, das das
gesamte Leben verändert,
so wie ich es tun würde  Sagen wir, dass Form eins, nämlich die
Organisation der Tierform, aus zwei
verschiedenen Arten von Formen sozusagen
horizontal ist, aber für die Person eine
Form höherer Ordnung von einer sozusagen vertikal ist,
also ist es eine Komplexität in der
Reflexionsphase von Richmond, in der sich diese Beziehung
beispielsweise manifestiert
Selbstbewusstsein ebenso wie in
Beziehungen zweiter Ordnung oder in Freiheit
Selbstbestimmung, also beziehe ich mich auf mich selbst,
also ist es kein zweites Unterscheidungsmerkmal  ct zweite
Form, die von meiner lebendigen
Existenz getrennt ist, aber es ist die lebendige Existenz
als eine Form, die selbstreflexiv wird
und auf sich selbst verweist, es ist sozusagen ein Abschluss
, keine Hinzufügung, und ich werde auch
argumentieren, dass nicht einzelne Fähigkeiten
transformiert werden, wie ich die Vernunft meine  oder
Selbstbewusstsein, was auch immer ein Wille ist, aber
es ist das gesamte Leben, das
so transformiert wird, und kommen wir
zur Ontologie der Person, also
möchte ich einen Umriss dessen geben, was
die logische Theorie des
Personraums können könnte, aber ganz kurz  Ich würde also
argumentieren, dass Lebewesen nicht
alleine existieren, sondern in
Fortpflanzungsbeziehungen stehen, also hat jedes
Lebewesen einen Vorfahren, hat
sozusagen Verwandte, dies ist nur
im Grunde Tier,
auch Lebewesen sind ein solcher Teil einer
komplexen natürlichen Beziehung von
Umwelt, die mit Begriffen der Ökologie beschrieben werden kann,
also denke ich, dass wir
das Leben nur zur biologischen Existenz reproduzieren müssen,
aber wir müssen die
gesamte Umwelt berücksichtigen  Es ist zwar ein wenig
ganzheitliche Betrachtungsweise, aber ich möchte
diesen Begriff nicht verwenden, es sind nur Beziehungen, in
denen Leben stattfindet, ohne die das
Leben nicht Leben wäre. Ich denke, es
wäre eine verkürzende Auffassung
, diese ökologischen Fragen herauszugreifen oder auszuschließen
Daher denke ich, dass Ökologie wirklich entscheidend ist,
weil es die Situation ist, in der wie
Leben stattfinden kann, also würde ich schwerer
als der menschliche Raum, den wir brauchen,
als eine Art höhere Form der
natürlichen Ökologie konzipiert werden, die
reflektierende Regeln der Interaktion entwickelt hat, also ist es
ein  höhere Ordnung, weil das in
meinen Begriffen persönlicher Raum wäre und diese Regeln
reflektierte Regeln der Interaktion wären
Moralkunst, was ich gesagt habe, ist
kulturelle Infrastruktur sind Institutionen, denen
ich da zustimmen würde, aber ich würde sagen,
dass dies Ökologie ist, natürliche Ökologie
, die auch selbstreflexiv wird
darüber nachdenken, über sich selbst nachzudenken,
über die Intersubjektivitätsmoral der anderen Person nachzudenken, die
entsteht, dies
ist in meinem eigenen persönlichen Raum und diese
r  Regeln und Gesetze Diese Lamas höherer Ordnung
müssen nicht unbedingt den Naturgesetzen folgen,
sondern können sich sogar gegen die
Natur richten
Obwohl es
aus der Natur stammt, aber ich würde sogar
diese Fälle auch einschließen, indem ich sagte, Folter bei meinen
Kindern, wenn ich mich dafür interessiere, ist das
Konzept des Bösen. Ich würde auch sagen, dass
die Vorstellung des Bösen oder Phänomens
nur innerhalb eines Persönlichen stattfinden kann
Raum Ich würde sagen, dass der Begriff des
moralischen Bösen nicht zutrifft, weil er
nicht auf die Natur als solche zutrifft, auf
Tiere können wir nicht sagen, dass sie
in jedem Sinne böse sind, sie könnten vielleicht
auf eine Weise grausam sein, aber es ist ihre Natur, dass wir es
nicht sind  erlaubt, eine normative Interpretation darüber zu geben,
dass also normative
Konzepte Normativität stattfindet,
die angewendet werden kann, normative Begriffe
können nur auf den persönlichen Raum angewendet werden, das
heißt, selbst wenn es cu gibt  lture,
die Unmoral ist, ist sofort involviert,
weil es unsere freie Entscheidung ist, nicht
nur moralisch gute Individuen, es gibt
immer die Möglichkeit der Aktivität in einem
moralisch Bösen, also ist dies meine sehr kurze
Skizze darüber, was meiner Meinung nach
auf logischen Begriffen basiert, also vielen Dank
dafür  deine Zeit